Hello. My name is Birke Baehr, and I'm 11 years old.
I came here today to talk about what's wrong with our food system.
First of all, I would like to say that I'm really amazed...
...at how easily kids are led to believe all the marketing and advertising on TV,...
...at public schools and pretty much everywhere else you look.
It seems to me like, corporations are always trying to get kids like me...
...to get their parents to buy stuff that really isn't good for us or the planet.
Little kids, especially, are attracted by colorful packaging and plastic toys.
I must admit, I used to be one of them.
I also used to think that all of our food came from these happy, little farms...
...where pigs rolled in mud and cows grazed on grass all day.
What I discovered was this is not true.
I began to look into this stuff on the Internet, in books...
...and in documentary films, in my travels with my family.
I discovered the dark side of the industrialized food system.
First, there's genetically engineered seeds and organisms.
That is when a seed is manipulated in a laboratory to do something not intended by nature.
...and don't even get me started on the confined animal feeding operations, called CAFOs.
Conventional farmers use chemical fertilizers...
...made from fossil fuels that they mix with the dirt to make plants grow.
They do this because they've stripped the soil from all nutrients...
...from growing the same crop over and over again.
So I ask myself, "How can I change?"
"How can I change these things?"
This is what I found out.
I discovered that there's a movement for a better way.
I want you to know that we can all make a difference...
...by making different choices,...
...by buying our food directly from local farmers,...
...or neighbors we know in real life.
Some people say organic or local food is more expensive,...
...but is it really?
With all these things I've been learning about the food system,...
...it seems to me that we can either pay the farmer, or we can pay the hospital.
I know...
Now, I know definitely which one I would choose.
So next time you're at the grocery store, think local,...
...choose organic, know your farm, and know your food. Thank you.